well now world powers are gathering in
berlin for a new push to secure a
lasting peace deal in libya
in these talks which are led by germany
and the united states
leaders will be discussing their pledges
to withdraw foreign fighters from the
north african country
they also want to ensure the war and
torrent state stays on track toward its
december general elections
libya has been unstable since a
nato-backed uprising toppled long-time
leader muammar gaddafi
in 2011. the oil-rich country was then
divided between a un-supported
government in the capital and rival
authorities based in the country's east
before a transitional government took
power earlier this year
foreign minister heiko maas said that
many challenges still lie ahead in the
pursuit for a stable libya
this is the man muammar gaddafi whose
brutal reign kept libya together
for 40 years in 2011
protests against his rule quickly grew
into a country-wide rebellion
in september 2011 gaddafi was captured
and killed by a militia group
the country soon fell into chaos armed
groups that had been active against his
regime
refused to disband and regional
rivalries
grew elections failed to bring the
country together
and soon rival governments were set up
in the western and eastern parts of the
country
the general national accord in tripoli
was recognized by many western countries
but it had little power over much of the
country
the rival government in tobruk in the
east was
allied with a faction called libyan
national army
led by strongman khalifa haftar
the two sides fought and attended
multiple peace conferences in europe
and continued to fight
meanwhile people smugglers took
advantage of the lawlessness
to use libya as a transit route bringing
migrants and refugees
to libya's mediterranean coast the
european union cut deals with libyan
forces
to try to keep migrants back leaving
hundreds of thousands
stranded in the country
in january 2020 the two warring sides
came to berlin
along with an array of international
leaders to try
to come to an agreement and end foreign
involvement
finally in october 2020 the warring
sides agreed to a ceasefire in all areas
of libya
a u.n resolution helped stabilize the
conflict
by making the berlin agreement legally
binding for its members on the
international level
all in all this led to the formation of
an interim unity government
that's set to stay in place until
elections planned in december of this
year
and for more on that let's bring in now
roderick cusaveta he is
a member of the german parliament's
foreign affairs committee welcome to you
and thank you so much for joining us
i'd just like to begin by asking you
about what we heard about there in that
piece
one of the goals being to secure
elections in december
how realistic are you seeing that given
the complications on the ground right
now
yeah thank you very much indeed we need
to be very sober
whether the election might take place or
not is not clear so far because
there are really different interests
however it is so important that the
german government is continuing its
process
of the berlin talks and that means that
we now
bind in the new transistor transitional
government of libya
which is taking part first time and
several
very important foreign ministers are
present like
foreign minister blinken the foreign
minister of libya but also from some
european states and others so i believe
that there is a good sign to the libyan
population
and second we need to press
those countries who offer mercenaries
military mercenaries
to libya we need to keep the pressure
and try to build up
functioning state structures
guaranteeing security if this
will be the case then elections might
take place
i'd like to ask you a little bit more
about those foreign fighters um that you
just mentioned there because the u.n
warned recently that progress has been
stalled
um that that is actually a prerequisite
also
for elections the the removal of those
foreign fighters from the country
some 20 000 of them are in the country
we understand by
by recent estimates supported by russia
turkey
and others how likely do you see a
meaningful agreement
to make progress on that front
well the german government is holding
background talks
with those countries who are supporting
foreign fighters
but second we could also find an
arrangement
where these mercenaries become part of
the security structure
controlled by united nations for example
as long as the land-owned
security structures are not yet
functioning second
i believe that on the long term we need
the presence
of international engagement for example
of the european union or of the arab
the african union i believe
we should really engage the key leaders
of the african union
that they take over responsibility and
this could be supported by the european
union under the umbrella of the united
nations
this would be a way out which will
guarantee
security on the one side but also needs
acceptance by the libyan population
and if the african union is owning the
process
this would be really a good progress
okay so that that would be one potential
approach there
in the meantime i'd like to ask you
about civilians in all of this
because the u.n is estimating some 1.3
million people are in need of
humanitarian assistance in the in the
country to what extent
is improving the situation for the
libyan people themselves
also on the agenda right now
yeah the libyan population is really
under pressure
but on the other side we have a split of
the national bank
we have a split of the national petrol
system
but on the other side the money is
guaranteed so there is a
is a lot of uh own earned
uh capital inside the country which is
also distributed
to the families nevertheless we have a
strong
need for engagement also of the united
nations
regarding the refugees the migrants who
are sometimes kept as hostages
in prisons or in the kind of
camps and there we need an international
control and access for the united
nations
also the european union could take over
responsibility so
the libyan population is not the problem
it's the migrants
it's those who are unemployed unemployed
migrants
and it's the question how to take care
of those who are exploited by traffic uh
by those who are trafficking the people
participate thank you so much for
joining us
against this backdrop of world powers
gathering in berlin for a new push to
secure a lasting peace deal
in libya as we mentioned you're a member
of the german parliament's foreign
affairs committee thanks for your time
you